s'agissant de la libye je veux redire
ici combien sa stabilisation est
fondamentale pour la sécurité de
l'europe et du sel c'est pourquoi
j'appelle à la reprise immédiate des
négociations et d'un dialogue politique
en vue d'un cessez le feu
nous devons en finir avec les arrivées
massives d'armes de mercenaires dans ce
pays
nous le répétons depuis trois ans depuis
les sommets de la celle saint cloud et
de paris il n'y a pas de solution
militaire en libye seule une solution
politique à laquelle nous avons
constamment contribué est possible la
zone méditerranée sera le défi des
prochaines années tant les facteurs de
crise qui s'y conjuguent sont nombreux
contestations des zones maritimes
affrontements entre pays riverains
déstabilisation de la libye migration
trafic accès aux ressources un jeu de
nouvelles puissances
si nous aussi l'europe à haïr redéfinir
son rôle et sa place sans naïveté sans
complaisance ce qui suppose de savoir
réinterroger la cohérence de nos grandes
alliances sur ce point je me suis déjà
exprimé avec clarté je crois ce qui
suppose de demander à chacun la
cohérence de ses actions
mais ce qui suppose pour nous européens
d'être clair et exigeant la méditerranée
ne peut construire une paix durable sont
nous nous ne pouvons accepter que notre
avenir soit construit par d'autres
puissances
nous parlons là de notre voisinage de
notre sécurité de notre stabilité
c'est pourquoi j'appelle au
développement d'une véritable politique
européenne pour la méditerranée c'est à
mon sens une nécessité et une urgence